okay well good evening everyone and
welcome to the July meeting of the
executive
um we've got special guests watching us
today we've got some members of
Stratford wi who've come to see how a
next meeting works and then I'll take
them on a quick tour of the Town Hall
after we finish this evening conscious
that the last time a labor politician
was in the audience or had an audience
of wi people it didn't end that well so
I'm hoping I don't get slow hand clapped
by you this evening
um but you're most welcome welcome to
Trafford Council
um in terms of attendance um we've got
apologies from councilor James Wright
has anyone else got apologies to
um offer apologies have been received
from councilor Carter thank you very
much thank you for that
um are there any Declarations of
Interest
okay if we move on to item three which
is the minute are we happy to accept and
approve the minutes from last time I
propose
well supported thank you very much now
moving on to section four we have got uh
several questions from the public this
time and what I'm going to do is pass
over to our monitoring officer for the
evening and Emma malpas who will read
each question and then the relevant exec
member will respond so Emma I'll pass on
to you for the first question
thank you leader a number of questions
have been received from the public for
this evening's meeting to ensure that
all questions can be answered within the
allotted time I will be summarizing the
key elements of each question each
question in full will however be set out
and published within the minutes
following this meeting the first three
questions are from Eleanor Horner
question number one with reference to
agenda item number eight are the ghostly
Lane and slash or the Dunham road
schemes refer to in paragraph 3.4 the
same as the scheme that was approved on
12th October
2022 question number two have there been
any significant design amendments to the
scheme are set out in the report that
was approved in October and question
number three please confirm that the
scheme was approved that was approved in
October is fully funded and proceeding
to delivery in Autumn 2023 and not being
delayed in the reprioritization of mcf
funded schemes
thank you Adam if I pass on to councilor
Aiden Williams to respond
thank you chair and um thank you to Miss
Hannah for submitting her questions and
I'll turn through them as we receive
them in respect to the glossy Lane and
Dunn Road scheme referred to in
paragraph 3.4 the report I can confirm
that it is the same scheme that was
approved on the 12th of October 2022 in
regards to whether or not there are any
significant changes to that scheme I can
mean that there's no significant changes
the designs have been referringed in
terms of technical aspects such as Road
Safety audits drainage and tree
placements but we wouldn't consider that
there have been any significant changes
and um in respect of whether or not it's
this this scheme that was um approved in
October is fully funded and proceeding
to delivery in Autumn 2023 I can confirm
that it is fully funded
um it sits within tfgm and in this
instance the delivery partner is tfjm
isn't Trafford Council and they'll be
looking to appoint a contractor towards
the end of August 2023 with words to
start there after thank future
thank you councilor Williams if we move
on now to the next questions thank you
Emma
the next question is from Andrew Gould
this relates to the urmston active
neighborhood section of agenda item
number eight Mr Gould expresses concerns
relating to measures being implemented
that will restrict resident access he's
unclear of what the scheme seeks to
achieve and identifies that it may
result in increased traffic activity
around Canterbury Road and the
children's playground in the immediate
vicinity Mr Gould is against plans for
the scheme continuing and asks will the
portion of Route D around Canterbury
Road now be excluded from urmston active
neighborhood permanently
thank you now pass back to councilor
Aiden Williams to respond thank you
chair um the council fears consulted a
range of stakeholders and proposals to
introduce more active travel measures
for the ernstein active neighborhood
scheme in 2020 as part of her Merrell
challenge fund application consultation
was met with a high degree of Interest
with over 3 400 comments received and
600 individuals attending drop-in
sessions and the outcome of that
consultation can still be found online
the consultation identified safety car
driving parking traffic congestion
around schools and dangerous fat ones
through residential areas is some of the
key issues for those stakeholders
resident feedback also formed a key part
of the development of the plans being
taken forward
um conceptual designs firmsden active
neighborhood were presented at Trafford
Council to the m41 area Ward councilors
and to transport for greater Manchester
in 2022. the designs were split
um in into several phases of the screen
beginning with interventions along eight
potential minor or major routes that
cover the whole of m41 area phase one
composes route c flixton west and Route
D Davis Hume Park including the
Canterbury Road estate they've been
identified as areas of further
engagement and consultation which is
planned for in Autumn 2023
in addition to that consultation the
intention is to include an option of the
truck of trialling various interventions
post the consultation and there'll be
further information released as that
consultation comes to the full thank you
chair thank you councilor Williams and
Emma have we gone to the next set of
questions thank you
there are three questions from Friends
of John Lee Park
first question relates to usage and
these are all with reference to agenda
item number seven what utilization rate
is expected for the pilot and What
proportion of these are expected to be
charged question number two relates to
outreach why have we not seen a full
description of a typical outreach
program and who are the courses for and
the third question is in relation to
examples and asks where is this program
working what are the numbers what does
the Outreach utilization and charging
structure
thank you very much
um if I pass now to councilor Kath Hines
to respond thank you leader um thank you
Emma for articulating those questions
um and I'd also like to thank the
friends of John Lee Park for their
questions
um so they've raised three areas of
concern and where they feel that they're
meeting with Council officers on the
18th of July to discuss the pilot
proposals didn't fully
um kind of cover cover their their
questions and I do understand that John
Lee Park doesn't wish to be part of of
the pilot scheme and this is reflected
in The Proposal
um however they have suggested that this
further explanation
um would benefit from it would benefit
those Parks who have opted to be
involved in the local Pilots so in terms
of the usage many of the issues that
have been raised regarding usage levels
and income and will be developed as we
work over the next two years with local
communities to shape the local program
and collect data or usage
um on usage and income generated for
each pilot scheme understanding these
factors and determining what works for
our communities are really important
elements of the pilot and which is why
we haven't yet provided that a detailed
breakdown of income usage and charges
however current booking data has been
considered and referenced in the report
as it shows Trafford residents and
tennis players are willing and able to
use the booking system and we've been
working closely with the lawn tennis
Association at the national governing
body and they're very supportive of the
local Pilots to test all elements of the
approach and consider how the Outreach
programs can best reflect the varying
Community needs and in each locality and
the lawn tennis Association have advised
that a Park Court typically needs a
collective maintenance and sinking fund
of one and a half thousand pounds per
year and the revenue model develops for
the pilot responds to this with a
flexible model and that can balance free
bookable access coaching and Outreach
and paid for slots demand data supports
a pilots and suggests there is
considerable latent demand for tennis in
the borough the demand data covers all
of Trafford and covers all ages within a
note 20 minute drive
um to the courts will continue to draw
on the lawn tennis association's
expertise and the learning gained as
they roll out the national program
across greater Manchester and wider
um in terms of Outreach providers will
be asked to Tender for the local
provision providers will be expected to
connect and collaborate with local
schools and clubs to ensure a pathway
and provide a range of sessions across
all age groups abilities and at varying
varying times and costs meets Community
needs while generating required income
levels
um in terms of examples as this is a
national scheme it is early days in the
rollout program however working closely
with Manchester City Council and Berry
Council we've been able to draw on the
learning from case studies both reports
usage levels of 50 to 60 percent per
week Manchester City Council has a
scheme with over 19
000 users and have demonstrated that
sites with access gates have more
bookings than those that don't and that
these have increased on a monthly basis
from April 23 they've also engaged a
provider across a range of parks Who
deliver Junior adults and family
sessions at all levels with varying
charging packages in place and this is
delivered alongside a rolling program of
course upgrades including installing
lockable Gates and introducing charges
for courts higher we will continue to
work with the law and Tennis Association
and colleagues within greats Manchester
and Beyond to learn from their
experiences good and bad and we look
forward to bringing that learning back
to share with the friends of parks and
to feed into the Trafford Pilots thank
you leader thank you very much councilor
Heinz and I think we've got one final
question thank you Emma
yes this is another question from Andrew
Gould it relates to the tennis
Improvement program at Agenda item
number seven Park friends groups across
Trafford have been engaged with the
tennis Improvement program for some time
most Parks have deep misgivings about
plans to charge a fee to access any part
of a public park the idea of charging
has been rejected by 80 percent of those
who responded to the consultation what
level of disapproval would it take for
Council officers to recommend something
more acceptable
thank you Emma I'll pass back to council
High Heinz to respond
thank you leader thank you and Mary
again for the question
um and thank you Andrew for his
correspondence
um the points um that he's raised and
for the specific question in relation to
the consultation and the friends of
Parts groups cross Trafford have been
involved in the project for some time
their opinions on each site and local
insights have been invaluable and we
will continue to work with the friends
of Parts groups as we progress with the
pilots in each Community we've also
worked um as I was just saying in
response to the previous question with
the law and Tennis Association in
bringing together the level of
investment required to improve Park
courts across the borough and as is
detailed in the report the level of
funding required of
um
587 000 pounds to bring our courts up to
an acceptable standard and ongoing
maintenance of 46.5 thousand pounds per
annum is sadly not one that the council
could meet given the current level of
budget pressures
um this proposal provides a significant
opportunity to work closely with the
local residents alongside tennis's
National governing body to learn from
their experiences and that of other
local authorities and communities as we
pilot this approach together
in relation to Andrew's question to the
executive on consultation and charging
and we do acknowledge that not all
elements of the scheme were fully
supported through the borrow-wide public
consultation process particularly on
charging equally though some elements of
the scheme were supported and the levels
of support for each element varied from
location to location as did the level of
charging that people thought acceptable
therefore the idea is to work out a fair
and accessible structure that will not
prevent anyone from from being able to
play tennis how we do that is exactly
what we hope to test in our local Pilots
we accept that the borough wide public
consultation process was somewhat
Limited in its reach by piloting the
approach in local communities we're
seeking to engage families Young people
local schools and clubs to gauge their
opinions taking a focused Community
Place based approach these local voices
were not captured in the broader Borough
wide consultation process to date at the
end of the pilot we will carefully
consider the learning and available
options to determine the best offer for
all our residents thank you leader
thank you very much councilor Heinz and
thank you again Emma for asking all
those questions I believe that's the end
of the questions from the public if we
move on now to any Matters from the
overview and scrutiny committee
councilor Acton
[Music]
thank you leader
um yeah we had our first
meeting of scrutiny for this Municipal
year where we actually look at prior
priority of items to scrutinize
throughout the municipal year
um
the what I want to say is that the main
ones that we wanted to have a good look
at were accessibility of council
services
to actually see how easy Trafford
residents find it to uh contact the
council online and through email or
phone to access the services and I think
that is a really important subject to to
look at in in in detail
um the next one is
um dampen mold within rented
accommodation
um and I think
um you know we we will be inviting the
housing associations uh to actually look
at how they are tackling damp and mold
within their you know properties
and again we felt that this was a really
important issue for residents living in
um Housing Association properties and I
think that's reflected in I think all
members as we heard at the council
meeting last week
um but whilst we're inviting the Housing
Association officers and we will also be
asking them about how they will work
with the council to reduce
carbon
emissions by Reef
um Vettel fitting homes again that is
something that we you know I think all
of us would would support
um and the last thing that we want to
question them on is
um how Helen Q planned to work with the
council now that they have been taken
over by Trafford Housing Trust again I
think an important issue so that they're
they're the prior priority ones uh and
it's alongside the existing task and
finish groups that we started last year
around man united and how
the community and man united can
actually come together in a better space
um and reducing car dependency that's
the another one for that is actually
operating at this moment the task and
finish group and that will continue
through through the year so that's it
for me
there you go thank you uh councilor act
and I think they're very important uh
priorities to have for the year ahead I
think the accessibility of council
Services it's a basic and so any insight
that you can bring as to how we might
get that better would be most welcome
likewise we had a very extensive very
good discussion at Council last week
about the dampen mold in in properties
and the work that you can do in that
area would be most welcome and also the
ongoing partnership we have with lnq any
attention you can bring to that is is
most welcome as well so it sounds like a
very busy year for core committee and I
know that as an executive we're very
keen to continue working with you and
the committee members uh councilor but
do you have anything to say from the
health scrutiny committee
um thank you
um we are having our meeting on
Wednesday our first one but uh we are
going to continue with some of the main
topics from last year which we are
complete and the reports will be
concluding on uh and they are some
really interesting further subjects uh
in the pipeline particular interest to
local news traffic residents so uh we'll
hopefully report to you on the next
occasion thank you thank you very much
councilor but we look forward to that in
the work program that you have in place
there okay if we move on then to the
business so we go to item six and it's
my great pleasure to introduce councilor
Kath Hines who will give us an update on
our culture strategy
thank you leader um and this is also my
great pleasure
um to bring these exciting proposals for
trafford's cultural strategy to the
executive this evening
um I don't know how many of us
um were already aware it's something
that I wasn't already aware that
Trafford is actually a talent belt for
culture and the Arts across greater
Manchester and with 25 of creative
professionals living in the borough and
the creative Industries provide 7 000
jobs which is 4.7 of all employment in
the borough this compares to 2.2 percent
in the Northwest and 2.3 percent for
Great Britain and this isn't currently
recognized it's a greater Manchester
level where Trafford is valued more as
an audience and for Manchester's culture
and creative sector rather other than
the workforce or the lifeblood and also
Trafford is underrepresented in terms of
external funding for culture and the
Arts with no trafford-based organization
being supported by the combined
Authority culture fund or by the Arts
council's National program so this
strategy will build on the combined
authorities culture strategy which is
grown in Greater Manchester known around
the world to ensure that Trafford is
fairly represented in the cultural
sector across across the region
and having the Trafford culture strategy
will bring hugely significant benefits
and which are documented in the report
which details the positive impacts the
strategy will have for our residents and
for visitors creating a greater sense of
place identity within Trafford increased
investment into the borough and benefits
for the nighttime economy
and the aim is to bring together the
rich and diverse cultural assets we have
within the borough from large
independent organizations like the
Imperial War Museum
um and Donna Massey or our big sporting
arenas like Lancashire Cricket Club and
man united and to our small and
magnificent Community groups and Council
run services like the Waterside and
gorsell Studios OT creative and many
more
um as set out in the report the strategy
recognizes the importance of local
resources local traditions and customs
and lots to promote these further to
improve the boroughs image and pride in
place the development of this strategy
has been a journey and commissioning
support from mctc
um and there's been extensive research
and engagement by a one-to-one
conversation small group sessions
workshops and a cultural Summit in June
which was attended by a broad range of
stakeholders Community groups corporate
organizations creatives and artists and
I was really lucky actually to have been
able to attend that culture Summit and I
have to say there was a real Buzz in the
rooms the organizations fed into the
strategy but also made real tangible
links with each other in how to support
each other
um it is really important
um that both the vision and aims of this
strategy do reflect that culture in
Trafford should be inclusive for
everyone
um the report contains 19
recommendations which are groups under
three inclusive community and
grassroot-led strategic aims these can
be found at section two of the report
together with the full vision and aims
for the strategy and the full strategy
can be found at appendix one and the
implementation plan recommendations are
also set out in the report highlighting
the iterative steps that we will be
um taking to implement the strategy
um in three areas which is the immediate
activity that will build on the work
started during strategy development a
plan to recruit to a temporary cultural
transformation all and which will really
drive the work forward and outline the
plan to create embed and grow trafford's
cultural Network which is described as
the Hub and spoke model
um where the water side
um is is the Hub
um service review of cultural teams to
ensure
um they are in the strongest position
possible to embrace and model the vision
and aims of the strategy and the plan
requires Financial resource of up to 180
000 over two years and the executive is
asked to adopt and approve the Trafford
cultural strategy and do approve the
implementation plan and commit the
associated resources thank you leader
thank you councilor Heinz I mean I'm so
excited about getting to this stage with
with this strategy anyone who knows me
knows how much I feel culture and our
culture offer is is important for all of
us in the borough no matter what your
background
um if we just pause for a moment and
think about some of the things that do
happen in this world so for instance we
have our very own Waterside Arts which
has a diverse program of of uh
activities throughout the year
um the national venue of Imperial War
Museum North which is uh which is going
strong on the wharf side we've got inch
arts in Altrincham we've got ghost Hill
Studios as councilor Hines mentions
we've got sail Festival which is a
thriving Arts based event that happens
every year we've got alteringham Garrick
historic theater there that keeps
putting on some fantastic Productions um
that are very well attended we've got
our Oscar winners McKinnon and Saunders
who who won an Oscar earlier this year
and both councilor Hines and I learned
the other week when we visited that we
have one of the largest collections of
Puppets in the country here in Trafford
but we've just not yet done anything
with that but we're determined to do
something without we Council Heights and
we've got a thriving music service and
we've got International venues such as
Lancashire County Cricket Club and
Manchester United for football club as
well so there is so much there and then
when you consider the number of people
that work in the creative sector that
live in the borough as well there is so
much more we can do not just to
celebrate the things that we have in
place already but using this model to
support areas where we may have gaps in
our cultural offer where we may could we
maybe should be doing more to support
local communities with well it's culture
and access so there's a lot to uh to go
out and so I'm very very pleased that
we've reached this stage this evening do
any members of the executive councilor
Williams
thanks chairman I I won't speak at
length I just wanted to compliment your
point really I think what I value from
this piece of work is that there's a
real understanding of culture and its
broadest possible sense so when you
refer to I suppose them the Arts one
might expect that book to consider as
well our sporting offer to consider that
trafford's got a really thriving food
and beverage offer that it's now above
where people want to come to relax not
just to to live and that we've got
people coming from outside of traffic to
visit our offer I think is really
welcome
um I I'd like to just pay credit really
to the Consultants that have worked with
us um on this piece of work because they
provided us an extremely robust report
and they've gone into a really
um great extent of detail about what
next steps the local Authority can take
to drive this forward I think this is a
really long overdue piece of work and I
really welcome that the administration
recognizes that there is a role for
local government and for the local
Authority in driving forward and
coordinating the cultural offering
Trafford and I think it's just a sign of
good things to come thank you chair
thank you very much for those comments
councilor Williams anyone else from the
executive okay if I go to councilor
Evans first of all thank you chair I've
got two questions
um one on page 22 and the cultural
transformation role at 400 pound a day
and 72 000 pound 800 a year and surely a
good amount of effort to get full time
that's a lot of money and and somebody
that was actually
in it on a fixed term roll committed to
it and could roll with it I think would
be better I'd like a comment on that and
then moving on to page 23 item 5.4 the
intention is that future funding
requirements are met from external
sources EG Ace Place partnership how
certain are we of that does the whole
process uh rest on that and what does
future mean does it mean one year two
year three year oh that's it thank you
thank you councilor Evans I'll go to
council Hines first and then I may go to
Sarah after that yeah thank you
councilor Evans I think those two
questions are probably linked with each
other to a certain degree in my mind
actually so
um to your first points and and question
um
that um it it does seem like like a lot
um but actually that is the the kind of
the market rate for somebody who has got
that expertise who's got that kind of
cultural expertise who knows how to
um drive forward a plan like this and
the idea is and and it's not just an
idea actually you know a lot of research
has been done around this in equivalent
roles in other local authorities
um that they will be able to to bring
all of this together to make these
things happen and to then look at what
is the sustainable model going forward
and support all of those things in place
so that actually you know that the
strategy itself is bringing that kind of
income generating that income to sustain
itself now the idea is obviously not to
necessarily bring in
kind of an income for the the local
authorities to it's to sustain itself as
a cultural strategy so those two
questions I think really are linked
together
um and the
the linking already the the the benefits
of of even having the conversations can
be seen with some really tangible
examples in the room where the
organizations were linking up with each
other they had skills
um that were mutually
um kind of beneficial to each other so
they were setting things up already so
even having those conversations
um that the council was able to to kind
of to coordinate
um is already starting to to kind of pay
dividends
um but there is so much more that this
strategy can deliver and having a a
person to do that who has got the right
skills
um will be able to take that to the next
level thank you
okay thank you
um councilor Jerome
thank you leader
um a cultural strategy is something that
can make a real difference to this
Borough and there is much promise in
these documents and the green group
would support where we can
however there is a lot of mystifying
jargon in these documents too hyper
local Community Connection creative
Factory and so on the implementation the
implementation plan at 4.1 of the report
also says there will need to be it this
will need to be organic at times
therefore not all the actions are known
now
it seems to me there is little concrete
group grasp of what the achievements
will exactly look like
is there a danger this s106 money could
be wasted as it's a massive and
complicated undertaking with a lack of
definition in places
okay councilor Heinz
um yeah thank you councilor Jerome to
answer your last question I would very
much hope not
um I don't think that I don't anticipate
that that will be the case and as I say
even just having those conversations
um has started to ignite something that
wasn't there before
um as I've answered my answer to
councilor Evans I think having that
person who's got that expertise to drive
that forward will be really beneficial
um and a lot of work has gone into this
strategy but the reason that it is
organic is because it will and
necessarily constantly change to reflect
kind of how it will be it is already
Dynamic but it will continue to be
dynamic it gives the flexibility of it
gives scope for perform for more voices
and to feed into that and I think local
members yourself in included May well
want to feed into that with the local
knowledge that you've got as well so and
that will be very much appreciated and
we hope that you can you can all
contribute to that
um
I I kind of do agree with you if I'm
being a hundred percent honest in terms
of some of the jargon that's in the the
the the body of the main report and when
I was writing my summary I took some of
it out because it's not my natural
language so I I do agree with you on
that and I think in some ways it it sort
of um
it detracts a little bit from the fact
that we want this to be accessible for
everyone
um but I think that is the language that
that's used there so I just would ask
you to forgive that a little bit and but
there is a little bit of that that in
there I do agree with that thank you
just to add that CTC who who've
supported us through this strategy
um they are leaders in their field
around this they're very much embedded
in the cultural in Creative Industries
and have um have brought a lot of their
own wisdom and insight to this process
so I am not
I'm not worried about this I think it
will be very indeed it will be very good
value for money because what it will do
is unlock a whole sector that as a
council over many decades now we've
we've not really um we've not really
captured and and run with so I think
this is a front front loaded investment
in resource now which will unlock a lot
of both cultural but also economic
benefits to us so if we get the cultural
strategy right you're going to help help
employment you're going to help the food
and beverage offer you're going to help
bring more people into our towns so
there is a positive around our economy
so I am optimistic about this I'm
confident about this because we've
sought the right advice and they have
benchmarked they've looked at best
practice elsewhere they've looked at
what we're not doing which frankly was
quite a lot and we're looking to put
that right now which is what this
strategy will do
Sarah did you want to
yes just to um give councilor Jerome
some comfort the am hot off the press
and easy read of the culture has lands
in my inbox so um I will easy read it
and then circulate will absolutely
accepting the points around jargon
thank you um councilor butts indicated
and then councilor Ennis so councilor
book first
uh I also welcome this uh strategy Dave
some years ago I was on the board of
internationalization and marketing with
Manchester and one of the big efforts
that was made on that was to try and
exploit all the resources with the
ingredient of Manchester and trap it
always used to come out on top because
we were punching above our work really
in terms of the assets we've got and
clearly we're not saying that we haven't
utilize them as much as we could do or
make meters much benefit from them as we
could do but certainly uh if this uh you
know has been looking at ways of being
able to use all those facilities because
and it's an incredible number of
associations and societies within
Trafford that seem to be forgotten to a
certain extent not because deliberately
but it's just that they don't seem to
have any access I mean I'm typically
thinking of one which just happened to
uh come up which was u3a in the
university the third age and they have
several of those organizations within
Trafford and one of them came to me only
a few days ago and said we want to
let people know who we are what we can
do because they do provide for people
like people with mental health issues
uh and inequalities that they might
suffer as well and loneliness which is
another big thing that's increasing now
especially with older people
I mean I know in the corporate
priorities it doesn't seem to uh mention
things like
um this sort of loneliness and mental
health issues but which are actually
growing all the time perhaps at some
point they will be looked at but uh
I say
we just need to be able to signpost
people those organizations as to where
they can go to get that information
because
they just need that extra help and that
will help you as well in in terms of
getting to know who they are and what
they can do for people's not just from
within their own locality but for wider
field you know within traffic itself so
I just wanted to say that's good I think
one of the points which perhaps didn't
get quite covered earlier on from my
colleague was the the on the on the
funding side you know I think there's
any I think there's mentioned in Ace
partnership or something that uh we'll
be doing can you possibly just explain
who they are
so that is the Arts Council Council
about
um and we are working very closely with
the Arts Council at the moment to
understand what
um big rounds and funding pots we can um
access for traffic Council and also for
our stakeholders and strategic Partners
too okay thank you so if I could later
on perhaps get a like point of contact
for being able to
signposts that one of these
organizations that I've got that wants
to know thank you thank you councilor
and councilor Ennis
thank you uh chair can I just say I
really really welcome this this body of
work it's a substantial um piece of work
and it doesn't happen in a vacuum either
because we have to take into account the
decimation of Arts funding since 2010 uh
there really has been it's not an easy
place for for local government to
operate in at all so look forward to the
easy read
um and it looks substantial
um but just maybe if I could get some
assurances around two pillars of this
um as I'm looking at it
um we need to see that there's work
being done in every corner of the
borough and that Outreach is true and
all encompassing
um and the two pillars I'm talking about
really are the nighttime economy and uh
education and Outreach because that's
how you create a circular economy around
around the Arts um and if we could just
talk a little bit more about uh the
implementation with regards to that
thank you thank you councilor Ennis
councilor Hines
yeah thank you for that um I am just
going to ask Sarah if you can come in in
terms of I mean I would I would like to
offer you that um Assurance but just in
terms of how we're going to kind of
reflect that backhand when
um are you able to comment further on
that Sarah
so I think the the honest answer is it's
really early stages at the moment as we
start to shape the strategy that sits
around they support absolutely they are
core pillars of how we deliver culture
um right across the borough in each and
every part and is linked to the work
that's happening in the police and part
of the organization so obviously there
needs to be some real Connections in
that regard and we asked us and to have
those conversations with education
Partners too about helping sure we
underpin the strategy in that area too
but um I think it's it's a watch this
space but watch closely because I don't
think it will be far away
thank you very much for that Sarah okay
um so the recommendations are one and
two are set out at the top of the paper
uh all those in favor
hi thank you let's move on to the next
item which is the tennis investment
project and I'll hand back to councilor
Hines
thank you
um and apologies that it is still me
I'll give somebody else a chance shortly
um so I am really happy actually to
present the report
um to the executive and which is
recommending a pilot scheme for
improving trafford's Park tennis courts
over the next two years
um and I will talk you through
um that the report and I think we've had
answers to
um some questions I think which is
already sort of trailered this report
um and it is just to mention really
before I do start to to talk you through
it that we have been working with the
boroughs friends of parks groups in
securing
um investment for tennis and developing
the pilot skiing but it is important to
note that this report was published
um a little while ago and when it was
published it was our understanding
um that Davey Hume Park friends of group
had wanted to be involved in the pilot
and and that was our understanding but
actually and that is is not the case and
they have confirmed to us that they
don't wish to be included in the pilot
and so when I talk you through it
um I I will apologize that debutant Park
is is is listed there but actually
um as it stands the recommendations for
the pilot scheme and will be to progress
this with Longford Ashton and and
Pickering at lodge Parks
um with the potential for a a fourth
which will be in the west of um the
borough so
um
I am pleased to introduce the report but
I do also want to
um acknowledge at the outset that I do
understand why this item has generated
some kind of further questions and
inquiry from our friends of groups and I
think this is because
um it does represent some some change in
our Parks
um but it is very important to also
stress that the proposals that I am
presenting this evening are for a pilot
scheme
um and that's in response to the
consultation that we've done and it's to
Pilot hopefully in one part in each of
the four localities in Trafford
um and that is then to help us to
determine the best way forward for
tennis in our Borough so we have 31
tennis courts in Parks across the
borough which do I think it's fair to
say vary in terms of quality and with
some that really are in quite a poor
condition and sadly the local Authority
doesn't have the resource to invest into
the course to bring them up to a high
standard and it doesn't have sufficient
funds
um to then maintain the courts at that
level on an ongoing basis
um
but we do believe it's important to have
a sustainable and affordable tennis
offer in Trafford
um that means tennis can remain
accessible to everyone and not just
those people who can afford to join a
private tennis club and without some
investment the concern is that the
courts May Decline and that there will
be significantly less access and to
Affordable tennis the lawn tennis
Association
um who I'll just refer to as the LTA
have got some investment funding
available to local authorities for
tennis courts to access the LTA funding
we need to demonstrate a sustainable
model of Maintenance this means
considering a model for booking the
courts and potentially charging a fee
for some access however the local
Authority can consider its pricing to
ensure that it is accessible including
concessions and options to retain some
free access and the council has
consulted on a set of options and
proposals for a booking and charging
scheme that would also have some
Outreach and coaching available
consultation and engagement took place
with the friends of parks groups and
also with residents via a Citizen Space
survey which had 830 responses and
through two public meetings and the
feedback is set out in section four of
the report and feedback was not positive
with regards to the introduction of a
charge for tennis with 80 percent of
residents and stating that they wouldn't
be willing to pay a fee although some
elements of the proposals were more
welcome actually such as coaching and
Outreach in the public meetings
Reflections in favor were that people
understood the need to Developers
sustainable operating model and that
they saw the benefit of an operator to
reach new audiences and they understood
the need for access gates and would
support their peers and children to
access the system and there was against
a proposal believed that the court
should remain free and open for all so
access gates in a fee as barriers to use
that would exclude young people and
anyone who couldn't use the booking
system and consider an operator to be to
Commercial and exclusive we're concerned
about the
inclusivity of the engagement process
and timing of the process so
um given the feedback it is really
important that we do now consider the
options
um there are a range of options detailed
in the paper which can be found in
sections five and six of the report
which details the potential uh strengths
weaknesses and risks of each
um of those proposals and the
recommendation is for us to consider
option 3C which is to introduce a pilot
scheme in four Parks one in each
locality although at the moment we have
only got three
um identified for the reasons that are
stated a little bit earlier so
um The Proposal is for an access gate a
charge and an operator the pilot would
operate for an initial 24 months with a
quarterly review process that will
Monitor and analyze key performance
indicators such as user numbers Revenue
you Outreach engagement and user
feedback on conclusion of the pilot and
a paper will be submitted again back to
Executive to detail the impact of the
pilot and provide recommendations on
next steps on conclusion and the option
to expand the model to other courts can
be considered
um
although the pilot options secure
investment for for courts across the
sites that have been identified and
there will obviously be remaining courts
um that won't have that investment
during that um pilot phase
um but any future roll out of the pilot
would require further capital investment
which at this point isn't necessarily
guaranteed
um by the LTA but we don't know what the
situation will be when we get to that
point
um so
um the responses to the engagement
process and consultation have been
discussed with the um LCA and we've
tried to draw on their experience
um and options have been set out in in
the report for what we can do there so
section seven of the report details some
indicative Financial modeling
demonstrating that based on a pricing
model of three pound per quart per hour
with a billable period of approximately
10 hours per day and season operating
from May to September these courts can
generate the revenue
um that's detailed then in the report
um so in summary enabling residents to
access spaces and places to be active
does unfortunately but obviously come at
a cost and which will need to be met and
sustained without a structured and
sustainable plan for the borders part
tennis courts they will sadly
deteriorate and become unusable while
the response the consultation and
engagement State wasn't overwhelmingly
popular positive to all aspects of the
model the recommended pilot scheme
enables the council to strike a balance
draw on the implementation experiences
for other authorities and expertise of
the LTA to test the effectiveness of the
model and the recommendations are set
out in the report thank you leader thank
you councilor Hines does anyone from the
executive wish to speak councilor Patel
thank you thank you Cass
um for presenting what has been um
a very complex piece of work I know that
has been ongoing for many years so I
know pre-covered we started these
discussions and I just like to thank
officers exec members and the LTA for
their contributions
um
I support the proposals in the for in
the report as a genuine attempt to find
a sustainable future for our tennis
courts
um contrary to a lot of talk around the
the project this is and this is not a
great money-making scheme for the
council This Is Us looking to generate a
modded sync fund to ring fence to
individual courts to ensure that we can
invest in it in the future
um it's it's the wrap around is a
genuine offer to improve access
and opportunity to play tennis on on a
court that meets a decent standard no
more no less
um I was very pleased to join councilor
Harding and councilor Jerome on a visit
to wythenshaw park where we saw it in
action
um that was very useful and certainly
tapping into other local authorities on
their experience will be useful moving
forward and I really look forward to
seeing these Pilots evolve thank you
thank you councilor Patel councilor ad
said
thank you uh leader yeah uh lot's
already been said so obviously uh I've
got too much to say you're probably
pleased to know but obviously uh
following the consultation at the report
has been completely amended so we are
just looking at a Pilot now I think
that's probably uh the correct way to go
forward Bob because it listens to the
consultation but secondly it also gives
us the opportunity to actually see what
the demand is now when you read through
the reports when these other authorities
at Manchester and Barry have done them
they've actually shown quite an increase
in take-up of this sport I think that's
what particularly interests me if they
made it into a successful scheme that
then I think a pilot is way forward to
see if it's suitable Trafford as well
obviously uh if it does generate more
interest as you said yourself
unfortunately isn't guaranteed that
other Parks will be able to join because
it was like a one-off opportunity really
uh and I think it uh that is a shame in
some ways obviously but uh obviously the
pilot gives the opportunity to actually
see what it is like and I think also I'm
looking forward to see how we can get
the young Susan innovators that perhaps
can't afford them as part of the scheme
as well which is set out in Parts report
I think that'll be really good to do
that because at the moment it is
difficult there's nothing really
facilities there thing in the old time
actually bring on some youngsters which
I think is one of the aims of this sort
of strategy isn't just about people
going in there if they can get in there
uh I mean when I did pass one of tennis
courts uh if we get to see some dogs
running around in my own local park
which from that name but obviously uh
obviously something like this uh will
actually make sure that it's actually
available to people who use it so I
think it is to be welcomed this and at
the end of the pilot I think I look
forward to seeing actually what the
take-up is and actually if it's been
supported and what our options are but
it's not certain we're going to be able
to take it forward in the future there's
just a pilot so I think wanted to
emphasizes but none of this is a done
deal at all we've had some genuine
consultation thank you thank you
councilor ad said and councilor Thompson
thank you um I've only read some
research
the all the research they've put into
this it's obviously been a lot of work
of the research they've put into it
producing this really readable report uh
concise but with all the detail that you
need and thank them for all their
presentations they've given to us and
the friends of Park groups as well so I
just wanted to thank them
thank you and I Echo that thanks as well
councilor Thompson and any other
questions uh councilor Ennis first of
all
thank you chair just um maybe on a point
of clarity three of the four pilot sites
have received some positive support for
the sustainable operating model which
site didn't
um so so we
had any response from Pickering Lodge
um now we're not necessarily taking the
fact that we've had no response as a
positive response
um but given that they haven't fed back
anything of a negative nature and we
have because we we invited them to
um the feedback once we'd kind of
um we'd we'd
um published this report
um or we'd not we hadn't actually
published it but we were ready to
publish it we invited them to to a
feedback sessions talk it through as we
did with the other friends of groups to
gauge their reaction and and they
weren't in attendance
um at that either so we are hoping that
we will be able to engage the friends of
uh Pickering Lodge
um to kind of bring them into it
um but that is who that was yeah
thank you councilor Evans thank you
chairman three questions mini statement
accept counselor Patel's assertion this
this isn't going to make money
um and it's a genuine attempt to solve a
problem we have got a problem with those
and I hope counselor had said he's right
uh about Manchester and Berry being
successful but to me questions I worry
about section 7.2 based on a 10 hour a
day now bear in mind the bulk of people
in Trafford work
um is it reasonable and has it been
considered that actually with only two
of proper operating days which
represents 28 if it was booked out 10
hours a day on Saturday and Sunday I
think that is concerning and and then if
it does fall below 40 because we're
losing money at 40 who picks up the tab
question one
um question two
um we're dealing with 14 courts and
committing pretty much all our money the
quarter of a million 238 thousand and it
leaves us with nothing to go forward so
if this fails we've got no cash but
actually if it's successful we want to
expend extend it we've also got no cash
so burning our bridges as we step on to
do this and then finally to allude back
to the questioner which really doesn't
need an answer we did a consultation
eight percent didn't want it yet we
proceed what's the point the
consultation could have saved a fortune
and just got on with it don't need a
response on that third okay well I'll
start with your third one anyway if you
don't mind if you'll indulge me in
responding to that nevertheless
um so so I think
um 80 of the respondents to that
responded to say that they didn't want
to pay for tennis
um but actually this pilot proposal does
contain the potential for there to still
be some free tennis in those pilot sites
but given that we've currently only got
three pilot sites potentially hopefully
four there will still be all of the
other other tennis courts that are as is
that people will still be able to
continue to to access so actually we
have responded to the feedback that we
had I guess not responding to that
feedback would look more to me like we
just went ahead in every single site and
did it anyway so we have responded to
that the reason that we want to go ahead
I think is really clearly articulated in
the report that we want to see how this
will work and we want to see if we can
bring you know something that has
um concessions that don't preclude
anybody from playing tennis and a free
offer potentially of tennis still
um possibly on a Saturday so people can
still access that so that I hope does
answer the question that we have
responded to the consultation that some
elements of it we accept people weren't
happy with
um and we wanted to be responsive to
that
um in in terms of your question about
the um the the charging that modeling
there I suppose gives you based on that
that's what you
um would would be able to to kind of to
to make
um but we don't know I suppose we don't
know what the uptake will be maybe that
it may be more it may not be as much as
as that and I can't give you a guarantee
I'm not um an expert in that looking at
what's happened elsewhere
um and some of the work that the LTA
have done
um you know we're hopeful that we'll be
able to to generate some of that
um but I suppose in terms of the fact
that that we're putting some investment
into this and we're getting the
investment from the LTA we will have
courts that will be usable they'll be
fantastic and you know they will be good
courts that that people can use use
um generating that income means that we
can sustain it at that level but it will
still be there it won't just disappear
overnight
um if we don't make that and hopefully
you know we will make some that we are
able to sustain that
I am also hoping that um come the end of
the pilot
um
we will have
I'm hoping that we will still have an
option to to potentially access some
um some funding from the LTA at that
point so we can look at some of the
other courts if that is something that
they want to do at the moment you know
we haven't had a brilliant response once
people see up and running they see you
know people accessing it that might
change but all of those are ifs and
books and I can't I can't predict what
will happen at that point so I can't
give you Clarity on will we get that I
don't think Harmony in any event will be
wasted because it will bring those
courts up to a really good standard if
there's one in each locality then that
means everybody should be able to get to
one of those courts who wants to which
would be fabulous so fingers crossed
that that's the case I don't know if
I've missed one of the questions was
there another question I think I was
going to bring Richard in at this point
a better answer than mine yes Richard
uh thank you Council lines just to
follow up on the first one in terms of
the the usage
um so I think as uh indicated experience
from Barry and Manchester's usage is
around 50 and so that will get us to at
least a break even
um Point part of our uh uh physical
activity strategy and this ties in with
our physical activity strategies to get
a broader range of people active so it's
also about young people it's also about
older people so we're not necessarily
just focusing on people in work here so
during those daytime hours Monday to
Friday we would want the usage to be
from a wider range a wider range range
and also recognizing
um that at least six weeks of this is
across the summer holidays as well so we
want to be maximizing there and I think
also proportionally whilst clearly we
don't want to run at a loss at a 40
figure the amount that we're having to
put in is less than three thousand
pounds a year so all every pony accounts
as we've all said very often around this
table but within within the overall
scale of the Council budget I think less
than three thousand pounds a year we can
probably all agree is uh marginal on the
second point on investment yeah you're
right in the way we are putting our eggs
in uh in kind of in 14 baskets on these
uh carts here but that's about
maximizing the investment so actually by
going down this route
we're getting a pound from the LTA for
every pound that we're putting in so
actually we're doubling the benefit of
the investment that we're putting in
that's part of the way that we're going
down this route and as Council iron said
the intention if the pilot is successful
and we can demonstrate that we're both
that would be able to reach an expand
the use of it as we're increasing
numbers we would want then to be able to
go back and talking so the other friends
of Parts groups to see if there was
interest elsewhere and talking to the LT
about potential future funding for
future rounds of this we can't guarantee
it so we've been very clear with those
groups not part of the the pilot that
there's no guarantee of future
investment but we will be hopeful if we
can demonstrate a successful scheme that
the LTA would want to look to invest
further because it's certainly
increasing participation of tennis more
broadly is a key priority for the LTA
thank you Richard councilor Jerome
thank you chair
um we were specifically told during the
consultation that unless the council
agreed to a five-year contract model
with the LTA that this scheme could not
practically go ahead what has changed to
allow a two-year pilot operating model
across four Parks only
many of the groups feel
um this goes against the spirit of our
local parks where access is free does
the executive disagree with this
position
residents have also asked if part
covenants where they exist had been
fully addressed and can they be made
public especially concerning John Lee
Park
monies that are at the high end of
expectation could this be released to
improve other courts beyond the scheme
thank you thank you Council Jerome I'll
go to councilor Heinz first
okay so I'm going to
um defer to Richard actually in terms of
what what has changed from the five year
to the two year but I think the answer
to that is that we've had a conversation
with the LTA given up giving the
feedback that we've had
um and that I do know that they are
really really Keen to try to increase
access to tennis that we're not the only
local Authority that you know we're
seeking to do this
um and that I think they're really
positive around well you know increasing
access where you can is better than not
doing that so piloting it I think might
be the reason why that's changed but I
will defer to Richard and askings come
in shortly
um in terms of does the executive not
agree with that statement I think it's
it's kind of a binary question that
actually and I think it's a bit more
complicated done that I think I
absolutely 100 agree with you that
access to our Parks should be free
um do I think that access to all of our
services and all of our
um all of our resources should always be
free then evidently not because we do
um sometimes have to charge for some of
our services we charge for our Leisure
Services there's lots of things that
that the council
um needs to charge for I think what
we're looking at here though is this is
a way to maintain those courts we are
not able to invest into them we
absolutely can have
um those courts as they are and I don't
think anybody for one minute is
suggesting that we start charging for
the courts as they currently are and
that would make no sense at all so we're
not suggesting
um that you know we're fundamentally
changing something that people already
got we want to offer something much much
better than that and in order to do that
we need to find a way to Resource it and
when you look at the pricing for that
and looking at three pound per quart
that's one pound fifty each and if
you're playing double doubles then
that's half it again so it's not a
hugely significant amount that we're
looking to charge in and it is less so
than if you had to join a private tennis
club and as we were saying earlier you
know the idea is that you will have
further concessions on to that you'll
have different pricing during different
times of the week and the potential for
best to still be free tennis you've
still got all of the courts as I said
before that we're not piloting this
since this in so so um I don't think
that statement really is a oh yes we
agree with that oh no no we don't I
think it's it's more complex than that I
think we've explained that
um that and I am going to defer to
Richard
um I think in terms of the Covenant
question which I'm not too sure
of the relevance of that to this paper
but there may be something that Richard
can explain
uh I know that's been raised I thought
we had released the covenants
um to be honest and if we haven't done
that I'll check because I do know that
question was asked by uh by John Luke
Pat so I thought we had we had done that
but I will double check it out if
there's any reason why we wouldn't would
expect it to be on land register records
uh anyway and publicly available
therefore and I think on the the last
Point around while we may used funds
should we uh over it over achieve
against our expected income requirements
I think that's probably something for
the executive to consider uh in future
should that be the case rather than
something for us to answer that
hypothetical question now okay thank you
Richard okay so the recommendations are
one to three are set out at the top of
the paper all those in favor
great so we move on to item eight which
is an update on the council's mayoral
challenge fund active travel
reprioritization and the indicative 2324
active travel scheme
Council agent Williams thank you chair
and um as you've just indicated this
report does intend to provide an update
on the common position of the council's
efforts to improve active travel
infrastructure in the borough and such
from one of the Rapport provides an
overview of the original schemes that
were explored or scoped for development
and you'll note that some schemes have
progressed much further than others with
one component having been completed in
full
um upon my taking responsibility for
active travel last year the project team
have undertaken a reprioritization
exercise to determine the most effective
way to arrange Future Works this now
places a greater emphasis on delivering
a semi-permanent scheme through the
remainder Ridge Stratford allowing the
removal of the currents on the a56 with
a view to installing a permanent scheme
alongside the Regeneration of Stratford
Town Center
what's not contained in the report as
it's hot off the press is that the
public consultation relating to the
interim semi-permanent scheme in
Stratford has been launched today that
consultation is going to run for the
next six weeks and I feel quite
confident that this represents a
positive next step on our journey to
improving active travel
in addition to this our next major Focus
will be the urmston active neighborhood
we're progressing with design work at
present and over course those designs
when released will generate a lot of
questions from interested residents so
the intention is for a further
consultation to be undertaken later in
the year around Autumn time as I
explained in my answer to Mr Gold's
question earlier lastly section three of
the report provides an outline of
schemes explored that can potentially be
brought forward in any future round of
funding
the report is largely for noting share
but does contain some recommended
delegations to the corporate directs
place and the director of legal and
governments which I'm happy to move that
committee support this evening thank you
chair
thank you councilor Williams and just
say I I completely agree with this
approach to uh to active travel I know
we've all said before how important it
is to open up the options for people
whether they walk whether they cycle
whether they use a wheelchair whether
they drive we need to have those
different options there to encourage
more people to come out of their cars
and and use other forms of Transport
including public transport as well so I
really welcome this I really welcome the
the approach that's there we're looking
at around 13 million pounds investment
this next year which I think is quite a
significant amount of investment for the
area and very welcome as far as I'm
concerned do any councilor ad set
to uh later just briefly uh
obviously is taking some time to get
here but I'm quite pleased that we've
got this next round of the consultation
on the 86 and it's uh and the publicity
around that I think it's important that
local people do take the opportunity to
actually get involved and engaged with
this of and I think that that should be
quite Paramount and hopefully we'll get
some interesting and positive comments
back on this I know it's certainly a lot
of discussion around this and obviously
what make it safe for all World users
you indicated that particularly I think
particular of interest to myself is
obviously uh is actually the target role
section which is beyond gone for quite
some time and I'm quite pleased that
particularly along the different
sections starting but where it joins
that where where the roles separate at
Golden Chester Road there I think
particularly I'm quite pleased there for
the first time now as part of that
scheme when it does go ahead which I'm
sure it will is particularly the uh
extra pedestrian uh facilities that's
being put in there which is what I
insisted on a couple of years ago uh
because it's the one section that's
missing where there's no safe crossing
point for people to cross that's a bit
by Longford Road there all the sections
have a light controlled and there's
going to be gaps in traffic traffic
signals should say but in where people
can cross safely apart from this new
facility putting in extending that so it
will be safe periods that we've shown
that the one section was missing was
that section by Longford road which was
actually Bonkers really but it's
actually a busy road and particularly in
the morning Peak and perhaps other
potential Peaks where there was actually
no time when pedestrians could actually
cross safe there I think it was really
quite shocking it took us this long to
actually get down to it so I'm quite
pleased that this philosophy is going to
be for not just for cyclists or some
people it's just about things like this
uh will actually be included and indeed
if you look further just evolved from
here there'll be pedestrians will
actually be much safer crossing the road
with these facilities as well so I
welcome all those but I think
particularly we need to get on with some
sections I think it's been around a long
time I think cfgm actually I think well
it won't comment that too much obviously
we need to actually always get on with
now and get Spades in the ground and get
this little money to make these safer
for protections specifically as well
cyclists thank you thank you uh
councilor I said yes I mean we are very
keen to work with our partners transport
for greater Manchester on this and they
we've developed a very good working
relationship in uh in recent months with
you and just saying what you said about
Talbot Road as a pedestrian you walked
from the town hall down to Victoria Park
Junior School earlier today there were
clear gaps in terms of uh being a
pedestrian and safe Crossing so it is
indeed very welcome uh councilor Slater
and I think the report's really welcome
I think that people in Stratford are
really Keen to have um the work
progressing onto the a56 and I think
we'll all be aware of a very tragic
accident that happened over the weekend
where somebody was killed on the a56 so
we need it to be as safe as possible but
what I did want to raise was actually
this report will help with reducing our
health inequalities because you know the
active and cycling walking and Wheeling
they've got actually co-benefits for
people and because Public Health are
really Keen to be involved in a lot of
this work especially you know around
um
the air pollution that active travel
will bring that um you know there will
be lower emissions going on to into the
roads which will be safer for our
younger people our older people are
people who have breathing difficulties
also or reduce that um Road and danger
and also it will increase people's
Mobility so um you know from a public
health perspective we really welcome the
report thank you thank you councilor
Slater are there any other questions uh
councilor Evans
thank you chair
um
I'm just struggling on on the figures
when you consider we've just discussed
for quiet time 250 000 for spending on
our tennis courts and let's just talk
about the Talbot Road one which I
presume is this one outside that goes up
to Manchester it costs 460 say it looks
like it costs 467 000 to develop and
it's going to cost uh probably 4.1
million to deliver that seem I think our
residents will be shocked at those
numbers I appreciate this isn't actually
our money so it doesn't impact our well
I suppose it does because it comes out
of the mayor's precepts somewhere along
the line but they seem like eye-watering
figures to deliver
I don't know what you know I do know
what it's clear but it seems very
expensive I'd love a breakdown from Air
perhaps our accounts Department about
the Talbot Road how we arrived at 4.75
million please okay I will pass to uh
councilor Williams first of all thank
you um
um I suppose I defer really to corporate
director for the place Richard in terms
of whether we were able to provide a
specific itemized breakdown I mean the
costs that included here will include
design costs contracts across so on and
so forth and obviously we'd also have to
include inflation Refreshers in those so
um it may be that they increased about
the lifetime of The Works what I would
say is um active travel funding in this
country it's money that's allocated from
central government in Westminster to
local authorities to try and realize an
active travel Vision so in Greater
Manchester the monies are pooled by the
10 local authorities held by transport
for greater Manchester and then the 10
individual councils are in a position to
bid for funding so it it wouldn't be a
case of um sort of precepts being being
accessed in that regard I don't know if
there's anything
yeah I think I'm sure we can provide a
breakdown I think if you just look at
the top of the road that covers three
different Junctions there's a
significant amount of work involved in
those it's not it's not just painting
White Lines uh on the road so you know
the the they're looking at you know
moving statutory Undertakers moving
signals that they are uh civil
engineering jobs so you know they are
expensive but we can provide a breakdown
across the schools and I I would out
really you know if you if you've not
been to see some of these Junctions that
have already been delivered in Greater
Manchester so self it's done some of the
Cyclops Junctions they are um
significant engineering works you know
to get them done right into a good spec
um it is going to take
um quite a significant investment
financially thank you Jeff I think I
just add to that and I think that was a
very clear very good answer I mean in
terms of the value of it I mean if
you're a student that goes to Stratford
High School and you can't rely on the
car or public transport having a safe
Crossing is invaluable as far as I'm I'm
concerned and having that in place as we
will do as part of this scheme would be
very welcome likewise people accessing
the Leisure Center on great Stone Road
you know we clearly want more people to
be able to access not using the car and
having those safer processes again
playing to the public health point will
will be a win-win all around for us so
thank you for the the the questions and
I know that we'll get the separate
information if we can to you so uh
Council Jerome
thank you chair
um the amount of money we spend on
active travel is minuscule compared to
the road building program that this
government allocates councilor Evans so
we welcome this report
um with open arms and I'm pleased that
the money's being spent finally
um officers um tell us beyond the
current budgeted schemes that there is
little strategic clarity as to how to
meet the aims of the The Walking
wheeling and cycling strategy and
deliver the joined up Network that the
GMB Network requires
um we know traffic's congestion issues
are primarily School Run related should
we be prioritizing routes that enabled
active travel to schools and ensure our
spending achieves the maximum benefit
for our local communities however they
travel
also noting the under spend of
development funding and the strategy map
in the report can the executive member
ensure that sufficient Network
development work and engagement happens
in this calendar year and finally with
the alteringham bridge link the bridge
is being prioritized ahead of the
Barrington Road Junctions in terms of
need this is totally the wrong way
around
councilor Williams
thank you councilor for your question
and also your feedback in respect to the
works in alteringham
um I I suppose I don't fully recognize
the point you're saying about there
being a lucky strategic Vision certainly
that's not um feedback that I've been
receiving from offices I think a great
deal of work has gone into trying to
understand where we can deliver active
travel improvements and as I've said
earlier in my introduction into trying
to prioritize those in a in in a manner
that makes the most sense
um I'm just trying to think of the
second if I had a view with me then what
was your second question sorry
it's going
um I think this is part of a package of
work so um you'll know one of the things
that we have been looking to do is try
and roll out an a greater Pace a project
to school street so I think I wouldn't
look at any single one in isolation
um but certainly I take your point that
school up to school optimization is is a
huge priority the vision for improving
active travel is not about having stated
the art cycling facilities for extremely
enthusiastic
um cyclists it's about a school child
being able to get safely from their home
to that school if they want to use
cycling as that as their preferred route
or or method Richard I don't know if
there's anything you want around
I I think I'd agree I don't think we
would accept there was a lack of that
there was a strategic uh lack of
strategic Clarity
um I think we've got a very clear
walking within and cycling strategy I
think what's set out in this paper is is
a key delivery on that now we're out
along a key commuter route which being
the Long Island ambition
uh from as it covers the first part of
that from uh Stratford through to the
edge of the city center and then linking
into uh schemes doing delivered in
Manchester uh signposting other schemes
that Connect into that so it is we are
thinking about the connectivity into the
56 and and uh as uh Council Williams
said you can't it's not about seeing
this in isolation so this is a separate
work stream around school streets we've
got the pilots that have gone on this
year we're looking to rule out more of
more of those so very much thinking
about that
as well okay I just add very briefly to
that that um uh councilor Williams and
myself have worked very closely with our
partners at transport for greater
Manchester with Dame Sarah's story over
the last few months or so we're very
clear in our vision as this
Administration to um as as was
eloquently put by Council Williams
ensure that someone who's aged eight can
get to and from places safely and that's
something that we see is Central to this
and and I'm very excited by the
investment that we're securing from
greater Manchester combined authority to
deliver on some schemes uh councilor NSU
indicated as well thank you chair uh
walking within cycling all very welcome
in laudable and we welcome that speaking
of Transport for great Manchester um are
we any closer to uh hearing whether we
are going to get as part of this this
piece in the jigsaw really it's uh the
late night trams trial where are we on
that
um at greater Manchester B Network
committee on Thursday so I will raise up
for you councilor and I'll get a
response thank you perfect thank you
very much everyone so the
recommendations are a to H is set out in
the report all those in favor hi thank
you very much so now we move on to uh
the period two budget monitoring report
and I'm going to hand over to councilor
Joe Harding the exec member for finance
change and governance
thank you leader
um I am presenting this report budget
monitoring period two
um I do hope that all members are
continuing to find the layout of the
report on the presentation of the report
uh a lot better than previous reports I
certainly find it easy to read easy to
digest and easy to pick up on some of
the points so the part one at a glance
part two some of the narrative and part
three containing all the annexes so
thank you again to officers for
continuing to provide the financial
information in it in I will say easy to
read is easy to read as local government
Finance can possibly be
um
period two were obviously at the early
stages of budget monitoring and
um you know it's important that we keep
our eye on things as we progress
throughout the year
um what I would say and it's interesting
actually some of the conversations we've
had about investment and tennis and what
local government looks like just to uh
members attention to page 15 Outlook and
summary which mentions that we continue
to observe a cautious approach as to how
we plan the budget and we maintain the
budget we do have contingencies for the
demand-led budgets which are released
throughout the course of the year we
have the investment strategy which again
if we're looking at things like the
economic situation at the minute we
proceed with risk but we do know that
local government clearly has to look to
generate its own income so I'm
presenting this report for members to
note note that there is an overspend of
1.299 and clearly if you look at the
areas where it's all regulated we look
at things like those demand-led budgets
like children's placements home to
school transports the dedicated school
grants
all of those areas that we know we have
to keep are watching brief on but please
be assured that work is taking place in
the financing change board in relation
to how we can look to do things
differently to make sure we provide the
best outcomes for our young people and
adults who use our demand LED budgets so
with that leader I will table the report
for noting thank you thank you very much
councilor Harding has anyone got any
questions or comments from the executive
okay any wider Council but
a question sir first one is just uh
there's
not a grant allocation Public Health
Grant allocation 430 000
it was up from the greater Manchester
NHS budget or was that from the
government grant
yeah the greatest government and we
always tend to get late allocation of
Public Health Grant which makes it quite
difficult for us then to plan and
allocate but yes that's Government
funding because the thing is it was
actually a saving of 36 000 on that uh
uh
uh on the on them from the budget and
that on table one it shows that you
you've made a saving and but you've
still been allocated the grant though is
it was that because it came in late or
something or was that
yeah to that counselor but as I said
really
um the public health funding is
allocated to us from government and you
will know that public health bonding as
well tends to be ring fenced for certain
statutory requirements that the council
has to do we we have flexibility around
certain things but certainly Public
Health around things like smoking
cessation Sexual Health all of that is
ring fence for us to make sure that
Council provides those statutory
services
okay and the the second question was it
for me um clearly this uh it's quite
costly to put uh children into external
Residential Care you know there are nine
children uh costing two million pounds I
suppose just under a quarter of a
million pound a piece in a way and and
there's no absolute uh situation where
you could bring them in-house I mean for
example I'm just thinking I just passed
on my way in today there was a a house
on a56 which is the next Council house
large one in a subtraction near to the
old chicken fire station in fact just
further up from there opposite uh and
it's being sold by sulfur City Salford
city council for some strips our reason
uh those kind of properties which could
perhaps be
exchange or taken on uh and and brought
up to some kind of standard way you
could accommodate some of those children
I'm just wondering whether you know this
possibility thank you I will just sorry
sorry I was going to say thank you
Council but I am going to bring in Jill
in a minute to respond to some of that
but what I would say Council about is
this really but it isn't sometimes just
about the building you know there may be
empty estate which we could look to say
okay that would work perfectly to place
some of our children I think what we
have to look at is the skills that would
be required to offer the support for
some very complex children whether it's
the right thing to play some of those
children in borrow depending on the
requirements that those young people
have it's a complex picture and
obviously as part of Greater Manchester
we will have a devolved Health and
Social care budget and some of those
conversations are taking place but I
will defer to Jill to answer in more
detail
thank you councilor holding and
councilor both
um what I can advise the executive and
members this evening is that we are
actively and constantly looking at which
children we can place within local
provision you will have seen within the
report that there is a program and a
savings Target in relation to what we
call step down placements and that's
exactly the sort of thing that you're
talking about councilor boss which
children can we safely return to care
placements within the bureau as
councilor Harding has already said it's
not just a question of having the
property it is a question of having
wrap-around services having skills and
expertise the workforce and not least
um for any care provision it needs to be
registered with the relevant regulatory
bodies what I can say is as part of the
finance and change program we are
looking at whether it would be
financially viable for us to actually
develop any Emperor provision
thank you very much Jill thank you
councilor Harding
um there are no other questions so this
is an item for noting
consider it noted if we move on now to
the the next uh
agenda item which is the uh well coming
towards the end of the meeting now
um which is the corporate plan for
2022-23.
um I'm presenting this report tonight
the annual report which is enclosed in
the uh the item provides highlights from
April 2022 through to March this year
there's also some very interesting case
studies within the in in the annual
report as well so some of the highlights
that are mentioned are the improvement
in our children's services
um the poverty truth commission work
that's taken place our real living wage
accreditation at the borough and the
launch of the walking wheeling and
cycling strategy has been referred to
already and the moving strategy
um 20 million pounds successful leveling
up bid for Partington Leisure Center
um work underway a tall tree and Leisure
Center with um with with very mindful of
the um of being as carbon neutral as
possible there and look at
environmentally friendly build and
sustainable buildings there
um we have provided support through our
hubs through the welfare rights service
through putting out the household
support funding to people most in need
we've also signed up to the good
landlord scheme we're working closely
with our partners around Trafford green
hydrogen and also the Net Zero traffic
Park feasibility study and work is
underway in Stratford and we've also got
some recent public realm work to
celebrate in Altrincham so that's just a
snapshot of some of the things that have
been achieved in the borough and it
would be we'd be nothing without the the
officers that work for this Borough and
provide services day in day out in very
um testing circumstances both
financially and time wise so you know I
want to put my heartfelt appreciation on
record for all the officers of this
Council because they really do help
deliver for us in Trafford and make it a
great place to live I don't know if any
members of the executive wish to
contribute I'll go to uh councilor Patel
first thank you leader
um just to remark on the poverty truth
commission I was a Civic commissioner on
in that process and and just wanted to
thank again as we have done publicly I
know the community Commissioners and the
other Civic Commissioners that were
involved in that really engaging and
interesting and challenging piece of
work
um the the looking forward to the next
12 months that the key is to get a
meaningful Legacy from that piece of
work which I know that we're all working
hard to do and if I may just a shout out
to the sale West Hub and to sell more
Community Partnership who they work very
closely with for the wonderful support
that they offer to families across sale
um couldn't do without them um and very
pleased to see the holiday activity fund
up and running again this summer I know
that that's been really popular in in my
ward and just the Heritage Lottery bid
submission on Longford Park so that's
one of our already most popular parks
will become I think a regionally
significant part when we get that up and
running thank you thank you uh Council
Williams
thank you chair I did just briefly want
to comment on the performance monitoring
of the climate change work undertaken by
The Authority as I think it's fair to
say really that the rag rating shows
that we've had some successes but also
some challenges as we can see in the
appendices to the report
um and please for instance that Trafford
is once again performing strongly in
respect of recycling there's room for
improvement but it's very welcome indeed
that as I understand it we're once again
on top as the best performing brother in
Greater Manchester however there are
also some areas of concern that I think
it's right for us to acknowledge such as
our emissions performance and the other
thing the other reflection I'd make sure
is that I do question whether some of
the performance indicators might benefit
from reconsideration over the course of
the next year and I say that only
because I'm not entirely sure of the
benefit of us monitoring
um electric vehicle ownership
privately amongst residents as it's it
I question how much we can influence
that directly as a local Authority
um additionally I also think that there
is some good work that the authorities
undertaking that perhaps isn't being
reflected in the uh kpis
um I think they're about the
decarbonization work that one the one
traffic partnership is cracking on with
what I would add though chair is that we
have significantly increased our own
internal resourcing of this service area
I'm really pleased that we've now
recruited a head of climate change and
sustainability who will be joining us in
September
ensuring that we're monitoring our work
in respect to addressing the climate
crisis as effectively as possible will
be something that they explore and so
thank you for that opportunity chair
thank you thank you very much councilor
Williams and rightly you point out the
the appendix where there is some rag
rating clearly it's important we
continue to Target ourselves and
understand where we haven't achieved the
targets for the year and I think you've
alluded on some of those those areas and
hopefully with that extra resource we
could we can work work even more to
bridging those gaps and Council Slater I
think Q leader and I just wanted to
point out some of the stuff that we've
done around Health inequalities I think
that you know we're working really hard
to um get some changes for our residents
in Trafford because I think if you look
in the report you'll see that there's an
actual 16-year life expectancy between
our poorest areas and our on our
affluent areas and that is something
that we need to you know address as soon
as possible I think that you know some
of the stuff that we're doing around
smoke infestations is going to be really
really beneficial work also we're
looking at and vaping you know we're
looking at vaping it as an alternative
to smoking but we're going to look at
work now to try and encourage people not
to take up vaping and if they hadn't
been smoking previously so there's a big
piece of work that's planned and is
underway we've started the Trafford
tobacco Alliance and we've got lots of
Partners who are involved in that and
you know different and we've got the uh
Trafford Leisure we've got lots of other
kind I think off the top of my head
sorry we've got Trafford leisurement and
others who want to be involved in that
and to to deliver for us which is really
very important that we encourage our
young people not to take up take up
vaping and we did a piece of work as
well as well around our older residents
just recently because he hadn't taken up
pension credits and that has been really
successful there was there was millions
of pounds that our residents hadn't
taken up in pension credits and that is
now um you know that has been now
claimed by our residents so actually
that money is in their pockets and and
you know so hopefully that will prevent
um some of those inequalities but the
work that we're doing around Health the
work that we're doing around our older
our older resident well um Adult
Services I shouldn't say Older Adult
Services and around our Public Health
you know we should be singing it from
the rooftops we're doing really really
good work thank you leader thank you
very much Council Slater and councilor
Hines
thank you leader um and just nicely
really following on from
um councilor sata's comments
um I just wanted to really reflect on
the very very positive activity that's
taking place around the physical
activities agenda
um I think there's some real Innovation
that's happening there
um and that is not just going to the gym
that's all types of physical activity
um across all ages and abilities I think
the
um position of Trafford Leisure is
incredibly positive actually and
um reflects our objectives and and that
is not necessarily a picture that's
replicated everywhere in every local
Authority and I think that is thanks to
some of the um innovations that are
taking place thank you leader thank you
Council Hines are there any other
questions or comments uh councilor Evans
thank you chair and firstly I welcome
the new format it is so much easier to
read than the one we had before and two
points uh because it's a massive report
only two uh one that's page one five
nine uh key stage two has dropped by ten
percent which is four percent worse than
the rest of the country that's quite
concerning as we are a uh Center of
Excellence for education is there
anything the borough can do anything
Trafford can do to in improve that and
what are we doing and then secondly
percentage of major planning
applications process looks good
um I I received many uh complaints from
residents with small planning
applications is that in here and have I
missed it and could we have it for next
time thank you thank you very much
Council Evans I'm going to go to Jill
for the first question so in terms of
our key stage two results we got
um the first course of them last week in
terms of what the current performance
looks like and for the majority of
pupils in Trafford we are doing in
incredibly well but linked to the
earlier comments about health
inequalities for some of our more
disadvantaged pupils that's an area that
we do need to Target or analysis would
show there aren't any
um significant patterns and Trends so
we're having to look at the the real
detail to develop and enhance our
strategies but we'll bring some detail
back around that
on the second I can we can certainly
consider that in terms of measures so
Richard
so performance on uh householder
application so that's some minor
applications we know that has been a
challenge as far as the number of minor
applications that we got increased
significantly during the covert period
uh we're expected it slow down a bit
post-covered but it hasn't done that
does put a huge amount of uh pressure
they're they're often um very complex
even though small they're often quite
complex and quite and quite challenging
and quite time consuming we have had a
big push recently to improve performance
we have caught up with the backlog and
so I can provide you with some
up-to-date performance information for
uh last year I think whether we include
it in the corporate performance plan for
uh next year we can feed that into the
discussion when we look at what our kpis
are for next year because they've not
been agreed as yet
okay thank you uh councilor but did you
indicate yeah
yeah it was just uh on the page 1.8 it
was reducing Health inequalities there
is a chapter on Obesity there and uh I
know there seems to be a persistent sort
of obesity level amongst young people
one in four uh particularly amongst the
most disadvantaged communities within
the borough and it is a difficult one
and it's it's a slow progress one uh in
terms of getting it but I think it does
emphasize highlights not to reduce any
kind of active uh sporting facilities
wherever possible and you know maintain
those facilities if we can store
possible thanks
certainly you're right to pick up on
that Council but it is one that needs
focus and it will be getting focused
don't know if you want to say anything
uh Council Slater what and just to say
Obviously you know
you know when you think about our people
in our most disadvantaged areas that are
having to use food banks and you know
the standard of food that they are able
to achieve isn't the same as if you were
living unable to go to the Barbican and
the Unicorn every day is it so you know
the choice for some parents is to make
sure that their children aren't hungry
go into bed at night and I think that's
one of the issues that we need to be
looking at about um equality going
forward I think that some of the food
vouchers that we've got in for schools
for over the you know for the school
holidays and stuff like that that will
help for children to be able to have the
same sort of level of um food that
they've been receiving in school but
just be mindful that we do have a
massive abortion of our residents across
Trafford who use food banks and you know
the what's on offer is pretty much beans
and bread or beans and bread
thank you Council Slater
okay this was an item for noting and
thank you for your comments about the
format of council Evans it's uh you know
it's much appreciated
um so I can think we can consider that
noted um I don't have any urgent
business and I don't for once need to
move the exclusion resolution which is
always a joy so
um before I close this meeting I hope
that Stratford wi have found that
interesting and if you've got some time
to spare
um we will I can do a tour of the town
hall with you now so um but with that
good evening everyone and we'll see you
again soon